hello and welcome to this video playing
candidate master Sauron chess do we have
a name there
Nass me can do one from Turkey okay so
we get the Roxy bind now with me playing
like I had one with the white pieces
just the game before let's see how such
Ron chess is handling this variation
that I think is interesting for blank he
seems to know all the stuff oops
uh-huh okay nobody should be for this is
something that I tried when I was faced
with this line I think it's quite okay
for black at least the game that I had
was absolutely nothing for me I think I
rather prefer to like there quickly okay
so he decides to trade stuff okay I'd
like to trade one rope here maybe just
one look and then King tree seven is
good of course I have this double pawn
but that doesn't matter all that much 25
is controlling extremely important
squares and f5 is in most cases simply
get dissolving my double pawn because
there's too much pressure on me form a
field this is reasonably comfortable for
black maybe he can try sheet play for a
three before yeah he wants to trade
everything hmm it's not bad to take just
a little bit lame to take
I think I'm going to keep this rock just
to be a little bit more fighting so now
I've got d6 and everything covered so
that I can actually use the rock
question is how I would like to do g5
here in this position trying to play f5
later prevent g3 or four maybe not sure
I can also just play a 5 that's also not
bad yeah he's returning to this idea of
a 3 and B 4 so I wonder if f5 I mean I
think I should do it it's logical to get
those pawns in motion okay so he wants
to bring the bishop over to see to
understand well that also makes a 3
before bit easier to play so how do I
play here I think this is helpful in any
case yeah ok a3 before I take take 97 is
okay I've got the AFR then so this isn't
this doesn't concern me all that much
takes takes book a 3 then bc5 okay that
doesn't work group checks kingly too but
I'm always threatening ok 3 in case of
his before let me think about it just
for a second um no that's fine
yeah okay three now as on the agenda
does he have anything they are up to 145
I can play okay three walking is seven
hmm gee I don't know I don't see
anything great that's there that's
interesting I thought about this and
then night a for stuff it just it's this
is extremely committal but it could be
interesting for white so what is he
doing is he okay covering this might
make sense yeah and now he threatens
rooty seven very interesting
can he get something there was he five
or I don't don't believe in the exchange
sac I mean he's got two pawns but those
shouldn't promote yeah it's not
completely outlandish a little bit but
not completely
so king d6 Knight a form a newpsie aid
simply being ready to to sect the
exchange I would be okay after this
exchange sac and he doesn't have to a
sec they doesn't have to advance oh I
didn't see that move at all Oh
oh yeah at the end it's all about
technical tricks you have to see those
mmm oh that's awful that's awful okay so
this will fall have to somehow get to
look into the game now that was awful I
don't think that this exchange sack is
good for white but the way I played it
it definitely is
yeah whatever yeah cha cha cha cha cha
yeah I know I get this porn that's so
clear
hmm hmm maybe I can pull out some
miracle draw here
[Music]
time warning check check
whoa check that's unbelievable
check white resigned that was one of the
most undeserved wins ever Wow Wow
yeah interesting I mean I think this is
roughly equal this ending I'm really not
certain than to say three before this is
netting white all that much because I
have the a far I mean and this is
interesting absolutely interesting way
to play trying to play for the for the
SEC I mean after this this is really
interesting the section twice and this
was extremely stupid of course I just
overlooked c5 so I have to go here then
yeah and now Nellie engine and June give
c5 there certainly makes some sense yeah
and what is that this is what the
computer wants to do
activate the rook
it could be a draw in some way I can I
get those pawns the the Zulu I am almost
zero zero I can I can believe somehow
that could really be the case I don't
think he's promoting this all that
quickly I mean if he can't play
something like that yeah take all those
hormones checked I don't know
0:07 is somewhat curious why not zero
zero zero so this is the line that the
engine gives this this that's really
funny check check check check how can
this be zero zero zero seven to either
draw or not check no evidence okay yeah
okay yeah that's a draw check that's it
wrong hmm yeah they're very tough to say
I mean of course I should absolutely
genuine them in the game after stumbled
into this yeah maybe it's not an easy
win for white but black winning is
completely check completely outlandish
is getting this and this should bring
four white OS stumble into p53 in one
night yeah come on that wasn't good
thanks for watching